sie diesen irrsinn diese es ging hoch
her im bundestag gestern vormittag bei
der generaldebatte die ampel regierung
von olaf scholz im fokus der
oppositionskritik energisch verteidigte
der kanzler seine energiepolitik im
griff seinerseits die union schafft an
es ist gut dass sie in der opposition
sind damit wir die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes hinkriegen
damit wir wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
danach rede alles beide die
fraktionsvorsitzende der afg
bescheinigte der regierung zahlreiche
fehlentscheidungen und forderte ein ende
der energiewende den stopp der windkraft
und dem bau neuer atomkraftwerke
ihr vorwurf die ampel ruiniere mit ihrer
politik dieses land wirtschaftlich ihre
scheinheiligen appelle und
durchhalteparolen an die bürger sich
einzuschränken opfer zu bringen und kalt
zu duschen waschlappen zu benutzen für
die ukraine für die energiewende oder
für ein klima das können sie sich sparen
das wollen die leute nicht hören in den
sozialen medien sorgt derweil ein video
für empörung in denen afd mitglieder
unter anderem der eu politische sprecher
harald beyer links im bild einen
dramatischen brisanten winter in
deutschland herbeiwünschen in der
hoffnung daraus parteipolitisches
kapital schlagen zu können
und die partei und fraktionschefin der
fdp ist jetzt unser gas wir begrüßen
alle schönen guten morgen
begehen wir vielleicht mit dem was wir
gerade gesehen haben ihre
fraktionskollege im bundestag weil hofft
auf einen dramatischen winter hat das
zurückgenommen aber frau weil der
verdacht bleibt ja trotzdem oder der
eindruck dass die afg auf eine große
krise oft um daraus politisch kapital zu
schlagen ja natürlich nicht und das hat
auch nicht so gemeint das hat auch nicht
so wie sagt der kollege hat seiner
befürchtung ausdruck verliehen dass
eigentlich nur eine zuspitzung der krise
zu einer änderung der politik führen
kann das heißt natürlich nicht dass er
sich das herbeiwünscht was völliger
quatsch ist natürlich nicht die die
zuspitzung ist schlimm die energie
bepreisung geht da hierdurch die decke
aber muss natürlich auch sagen dass das
das resultat der energiewende ins nichts
ist also die grüne energiepolitik
zerschellt natürlich gerade an den
realitäten
gesagt hat es trotzdem ernst natürlich
dann noch mal anders interpretiert aber
wir kommen vielleicht zudem wie die
krise abgefedert werden soll darum ging
es gestern bei der generaldebatte
studenten geringverdiener rentner kleine
und mittlere betriebe die sollen ja
profitieren von diesem dritten
entlastungspaket und sie haben das
belastungspaket genannt werfen der
bundesregierung vor das land
wirtschaftlich zu ruinieren
ganz konkret was würden sie tun um den
menschen in dieser krise zu helfen also
erstmal zu dem entlastungspaket was er
eben kein entlastungspaket ist sondern
ein belastungspaket da haben sie mich
völlig richtig wiedergegeben das was den
bürgern heute gegeben wird wird mir
vorher über steuern weggenommen also
dementsprechend ist es ja eine riesige
umverteilung was dort geschaffen wurde
ist ein riesiges bürokratiemonster so
und gerade kmu s also kleine und
mittlere betriebe werden ja außen vor
gelassen die werden ja gerade nicht
entlastet und eine entlastung
flächendeckend führen sie herbei indem
sie mit den steuern runter angehen dazu
gehören die mehrwertsteuer auch die
einkommenssteuer warum entlastet man die
bürger jetzt nicht wo sie die mehrkosten
auf der energie seite haben und dann
natürlich die steuern abzuschaffen
auf den gesamten energiemix den wir
haben also wir müssen auch bedenken dass
die hälfte über die hälfte der
strompreise in deutschland keine steuern
und abgaben sind und das könnte man doch
jetzt entlastung heranführen die bürger
zu entlassen das wäre eine echte
entlastung wie auch die co2 abgaben
abschaffung die auch der co2 abgabe ist
übrigens verfassungswidrig aus meiner
sicht und eine echte abschaffen des eeg
steuern runter ihr konzept und sie haben
auch gestern gesagt sie plädieren für
den bau neuer atomkraftwerke ist das
realistisch in dieser zeit
sehr gut also unsere nachbarländer
machen dass deutschland rekrutiert haben
moment also wir haben eine eine
energiepolitik die nicht grundlastfähig
ist wir sind abhängig vom ausland wir
sind abhängig einerseits vom russischen
erdgas wir bemerken nicht wahr weil die
energiewende ja nur vollziehbar war in
dem wir uns abhängiger vom russischen
erdgas gemacht haben aber auch vom
französischen atomstrom so und damit
fallen wir natürlich auch unsere
nachbarn auch die tasche weil
deutschland sich nicht mehr unabhängig
versorgen kann und auch ein auswahl im
europäischen verbundnetz ist das heißt
wir müssen unsere energiepolitik unserer
energie angebot ausweiten ja wie man
atomkraft werden natürlich natürlich
also derjenige ist ja also bei der
jetzigen politik wo wir die grünen darin
haben die fdp geht die spd auch ist das
natürlich nicht realistisch und die cdu
muss jetzt mal ganz klar zu sagen die
haben ja die energiewende eingeführt so
und es ist nicht realistisch ich hoffe
aber dass aus dieser situation ein ein
funken an realismus entsteht die
verbliebenen drei atomkraftwerke die ja
nur acht prozent unseres stromverbrauchs
ausmachen wenigstens weiterlaufen zu
lassen die drei die wir letztes jahr
abgeschaltet habe noch im winter wieder
anzuschalten und natürlich mittelfristig
neue zu planen heute frau weidl fällt
der startschuss für eine kampagne unser
land zuerst heißt diese kampagne und ich
frage mich was meinen sie damit unser
land zuerst wer gehört zu unserem land
wer ist zuerst und wer nicht die
kampagne sagt primär aus dass wir die
interessen unseres landes vertreten und
das fängt ja schon bei der
energiepolitik allein an wie wir
vertreten die interessen natürlich nicht
indem wir uns abhängig machen anderen
zur last fallen das ist ja etwas was
überhaupt noch gar nicht auf dem tableau
steht dass wir durch unsere
energiepolitik anderen unglaublich und
seine nachbarn auf die nerven gehen so
dass das erst der zweite ist zum
beispiel infektionsschutzgesetz sie
haben es ja eben auch in den nachrichten
angesprochen das ist auch etwas
entspricht das den interessen unseres
landes dass wir die grundgesetze
aushebeln indem der ausnahmezustand zum
dauerzustand
gemacht wird obwohl die inzidenz das
überhaupt gar nicht hergibt also hier
wird er ein automatismus in gang gesetzt
abhängig vom zeitraum aber nicht an den
daten und das sind einfach solche sachen
völlig komplett gegen die interessen
unserer bürger auch verstoßen aus
unserer sicht ob das grundgesetz damit
ausgehebelt wird da gehen die meinungen
auseinander aber vielen dank für den
besuch hier heute morgen bei uns im
studio die partei und fraktionschefin
der sp war dass alice weidl und das
stichwort infektionsschutzgesetz haben
sie schon geliefert damit geht er
zweiter andreas dankeschön basieren